welcome back to the stronger buy science
podcast
in today's episode greg and i sit down
for an interview with dr christa scott
dixon
krista is the director of curriculum at
precision nutrition and she was kind
enough to join us for a discussion on a
variety of topics
including behavior change how to change
eating behaviors
common mistakes that dieters and
nutrition coaches make and how someone
might assess and potentially improve
their relationship with food as always
thank you for listening
enjoy the show
back to the stronger by science podcast
this is your host eric trexler today i'm
joined by
my very temporary guest host greg
knuckles but we are also interviewing
dr christa scott dixon how are you doing
today
i'm good how are you guys doing i am
doing extremely well greg how are you
pretty good pretty good very nice is it
okay if we call you krista cause that's
a lot of syllables dr
krista scott dixon yeah yeah please call
me krista
even when i was teaching university i
was krista so i guess i'm
i'm hoping that i'm still young and hip
enough to not be dr scott dixon so
that's my yeah yeah trust is always good
i'm the same way
i the only people i have call me doctors
just greg and my girlfriend but
everybody else i say please just call me
eric
so krista um stronger by science we
in the last 18 months have started doing
a lot more nutrition content because
i showed up and i i do the nutrition
stuff but um
it's possible that some of our listeners
who have been here for a while
um might not be super familiar with the
nutrition side of stuff
and therefore they might not be familiar
with you and your work so
do you mind giving us a very brief uh
kind of self introduction in terms of
who you are
and what your background is yeah
absolutely so i
write the curriculum i'm the curriculum
director for precision nutrition
uh which is we like to say the world's
leading
online nutrition coaching and coach
certification
company so we certified nutrition
coaches
that's our main business but we also
coach clients so we sort of do both
client and coach
end of things and so my role
is to oversee much of the curriculum
that we produce whether that's writing
our textbook for
coaches going through nutrition
certification or
you know coaching programs for clients
i'm doing less of that these days just
because we've scaled up so enormously
it now takes more than one person but
for a long time i was like a one-woman
show
uh producing most of the curriculum for
precision nutrition so
thankfully now that we've grown to
having 100 people
on our team i no longer have to do all
of that but that's basically my role and
so
it's you know essentially it's my role
is to be a good generalist
so it's to know enough of everything
about
everything that i can bring all the
pieces together and then
you know find subject matter experts to
to weigh in and to sort of knit their
perspectives together
awesome how long have you been with uh
precision nutrition
uh about 12 years i guess i think 2008
was when i came on with him and i and i
was i mean it was a small startup at the
time and i think i was employee number
seven or eight
something like that so yeah and i was
brought on
to to talk about the quote-unquote
female perspective the two co-founders
of precision nutrition
john verardi and phil caravaggio sat me
down
in 2008 and said listen we're two dudes
uh you know we're heavy into the bro end
of things and so we can speak to bros
but uh you know women people like we're
not as good with that we can't really
speak as authoritatively from that
perspective and so
you know would you be willing to come on
and kind of advise us on some content
for
female clients and um eventually female
coaches so yeah that was kind of like my
first
orientation to precision nutrition i was
brought on as the chick
awesome director of being a woman at
persuasion
that's quite a title
so so obviously i'm familiar with a lot
of your work
um you know you've published books and
stuff like that and
when i think of your work the stuff that
sticks out to me
pertains more to the behavioral aspects
of dieting so
um you know effective coaching methods
but also just kind of eating behavior
in general and my background i'm a
physiology person
so the stuff that i'm interested in is
essentially useless
without people like you disseminating
good information
so i basically have a ton of questions
to ask you about kind of the
psychological
and behavioral sides of eating and then
how we can actually act upon that and
hopefully
improve our eating habits either for
ourselves or for our clients so
um i guess one of my first questions is
why is it so damn hard to change
behaviors in general
yeah my goodness we could talk for hours
about that but
i mean i guess the simple answer is that
as adults it's not
really cognitively in our
interest to massively disrupt familiar
routines and so
uh you know the way the brain works best
is it establishes a series of routines
and
shorthands for things and so it's funny
like we we don't like to think
very much in terms of like actively
puzzling through things and problem
solving and
ingesting new information and digesting
it brains actually don't like to do a
lot of
thinking they'd like to do a lot of
running pre-established routines and
establishing familiarity
and so like they're kind of
i don't want to say design but they
evolved to prefer
automaticity because if you think about
all of the stimuli
coming in on an average day you know
you're listening to this podcast and
your butt is in the chair and your
postural muscles are firing to keep you
upright and
there's ambient temperature in the room
like there's just this unbelievable
amount of
stimuli to pay attention to if you're a
brain and so
to sort that out and process it and kind
of whittle it down
to the most salient pieces brains have
developed these kind of
subroutines that make
life more efficient from this
perspective
and so in an evolutionary sense yes
we're designed to learn absolutely
neuroplasticity is a thing it's
extremely effortful as anyone who's
tried to
truly learn a new skill as an adult will
know um
but in general the brain's default
setting is
homeostasis same old same old get that
butt groove
in the couch going and kind of coast
there and now i mean different people
have different orientations
to novelty versus stasis like there's
individual variation
but in general it's very costly to learn
new things and disrupt things
all the time i know how to write like
six lines worth of code so i'm going to
make this a computer programming example
so we basically our brain has its
established loops
and they work and it likes to run them
and any kind of deviation from those
pre-written chunks of code we're like oh
god that's that's a lot of effort
yeah and i mean and it's interesting how
much the brain will
will stick to things especially anything
that's like implicit learning right like
movement learning so for example
the other day i rearranged my cutlery
drawer and like my god if i i'm still
reaching
for that knife in the wrong place like
months later
like when i say the other day it was
months ago right and so yeah or like
when you um you know move where you put
your car keys or maybe you sell your car
and you no longer have car keys but you
keep reaching for your car keys like
a lot of the the implicit things we do
um
you know those are very much grooved and
we'll notice ourselves doing them
for quite a long time after the cue to
do it has been
extinguished that one really hits home
like the new car my cars my old car's
transmission
died just completely dead like three
months ago
uh yeah like four or five months ago um
we got a new car it also has a push
button ignition and it also has like a
little button for the trunk
and to this day i still i
just like poke a random place on the
dashboard every time i get into the car
because it's where the it's where the
the button was in the old car to turn it
on
um and it has proven
impossible thus far to remember that
that the button's in a different spot so
the yeah just
those those motor routines that uh that
very much hits home for me
and there's life routines too right like
i mean behaviors and emotional responses
that we learn fairly early on and which
we're often adaptive early on
are also really hard to dislodge like if
you have a way that you typically react
when you're emotionally activated
whether you get angry
or you cry or you know you go silent or
whatever
um those are also really really hard to
unlearn like if you've
ever tried to unlearn them i mean you
know it takes just an incredible amount
of conscious effort to do because those
got grooved in
so early and they were adaptive a lot of
the time
that's an interesting point you bring up
because i was going to ask
when it comes to obviously behavior
change is tough but
from my perspective it seems like
nutrition and eating related behaviors
are particularly tricky is that true
like are they like among the more
stubborn behaviors to try to uh
to kind of reformat yeah for most people
i mean there's always that like one
percent of person who
typically is a computer scientist or
something like that and they just look
at their nutrition plan one day
logically and say well this is clearly
ineffective and
adopt a change routine and off they go
but for most of us
yes they are very difficult and i think
it's because there are so many
intersecting
factors in them so i mean you have
millions of years of evolutionary
programming that has particular
preferences
for sweetness and fat and comforting
ourselves through food
i mean you have the environment that we
live in
you know i'm in canada like you know the
north american food environment
is full of stimuli and cues
the foods themselves i mean we're
surrounded by hyper palatable
foods that really spin our dials and so
they are very
entrenched because there are so many
intersecting inputs that
reinforce uh the behavior and the
inclinations yeah and at precision i
mean
you guys put together a lot of materials
that are
you know designed to help people become
effective nutrition coaches
and i would imagine an enormous part of
that is
not just evaluating one's own behaviors
but helping
guide someone through their own behavior
changes
so what kinds of strategies do you
typically promote at precision in terms
of i mean
this stuff is not easy to do so where do
you start with someone who wants to be a
nutrition coach and they say
how do i help someone change their
eating behaviors
yeah and there's lots of answers to that
question because i think
one of the tricks of being a coach or i
guess it's really the skills the art
is learning about people and really
understanding
what motivates this person and not just
in the sense of
being motivated but like what drives
them like what gets them out of bed in
the morning how do they
think how do they look at the world
you know what's their whole paradigm of
how things are and how things work
so i mean a lot of it starts with really
understanding
each client as an individual i mean
obviously there are types and there are
trends
but a client that responds to one
angle you know may not respond to
another angle so for example some
clients are very logical
typically these are your engineers your
sciencey types your computer programmers
like i said
and they like data so for example they
might respond well to
seeing data about what they're doing
which enhances their awareness and then
they use the data to make different
choices
or they like measuring things so i mean
they're they're quite happy to go off
and measure a bunch of stuff
then you have maybe people who are
living lives of such
mindlessness that one of the first steps
is simply to bring their conscious
attention to
anything that they do because they're so
rushed and busy and stressed and
scrambling and multitasking and just
like
so partially attentioning everything
that the first task is simply to bring
not even full attention like 80
of their attention to the actions that
they're taking
um and so this for these kinds of
clients we use mindfulness
um i don't even like the term
mindfulness because that still a little
bit cognitive for me
i prefer body fullness which doesn't
really make sense as a word but like
helping acquaint these people with the
relationship between cause and effect
when you do this when you eat this how
do you feel
what response do you get you know what
sensations does it produce in your body
and so forth
um so for other people like directing
their conscious attention
to what they're doing is helpful and
there are little ways to do it right
eat slowly is one of our classic
techniques of precision nutrition
and that i mean people always think
that's ridiculously simple
but if you've ever committed yourself to
really eating slowly
especially without distractions you know
it's like wow
it really changes your eating experience
another group of clients have eating
issues that are
secondary to some kind of trauma some
kind of difficult experience
uh whether that's you know childhood
neglect growing up with alcoholic
parents like
you know sexual assault there's all
kinds of things that can happen to
people
that ask them to use eating or not
eating or food control or
over-exercising or whatever they're
doing
to cope and with those clients we work a
lot on
emotional self-regulation calming
yourself down
you know managing your reactions pausing
like putting a
putting a pause between the urge the
impulse to act and what you actually do
so you know when you come home after a
tough day at work like
putting a little break in between you
coming in the front door and you
reaching in the stack
cabinet for example and then for other
clients it's just
basic like good habits like getting the
protein in there so they feel more
satisfied getting their fiber intake up
so again they feel more satisfied
getting their fruits and vegetables up
so like it really is a different
approach but i would say what unites all
of these
is a real emphasis on
simplicity and we've learned over the
years i mean
we've gotten as fancy as anyone probably
could like we
you know in our own experiments on
ourselves we've gotten super complicated
but having observed thousands of
clients it's obvious that the
simplest approaches are almost always
the best and
everyone benefits from core fundamentals
and so
you know no matter how we tailor your
approach it's almost never going to be
extremely complicated because that's
just not really what works
yeah and so when you're putting these
materials together or training
nutrition coaches do you kind of tend to
have a tendency to walk them through
some of these major
types of clients or do you just give
them a big tool kit and say
here's a variety of of approaches for
behavior change and
you know you basically just mix and
match them as you see fit
well we give them a process and a system
so it's kind of like a balance of what
you're talking about so
so rather than saying uh there are types
of clients
because that's something i think you
intuitively learn over the years
depending and
and those types are going to vary
depending on the population that you
work with right if you're someone that
works with
high school athletes you know the type
of person you're going to see
is going to be different than if you
work with a high-powered
type a endurance athlete executives in
their 50s kind of thing
so we don't really give so much types as
we do a process of reasoning and this is
something i've always cared a lot about
as the curriculum designer is teaching
meta skills
of critical thinking reasoning decision
making
just a really thoughtful aware like
step-by-step
process to coaching and so we use this
six
step process which really isn't anything
fancy or sophisticated it's just
kind of slowing people down because the
first
impulse as a coach is often to just leap
right into taking action
right you see a client they're doing
something wrong you're like oh god i
gotta fix that right away right and then
you tell them what to do
well a huge amount of what you do as a
coach is actually
investing on the front end which is
learning about your client right really
getting to know them and understand them
and then doing the action planning in
collaboration with them
so by giving this like system of uh
decision making and kind of like
procedural
assessment understanding action planning
uh
you know establishing your indicators
monitoring and follow-up reassessment
it's like a cyclical process it really
allows you to address
any client situation even if you don't
necessarily have direct experience with
it and so i think
you know the value and what we do is a
lot of it is in these meta skills
because
now i mean the laws of biochemistry
probably aren't going to change that
much
in the next 20 years but maybe how we
think about nutrition may change we're
a new it's funny because i was just
talking to someone today about
witnessing the emergence of crossfit in
the last 20 years like i remember
the very first crossfit back when it was
like an underground
weird thing and so that's a sport in a
way that didn't exist 20 years ago
so practices may change but if you have
those
meta skills you can adapt yeah
and so you mentioned that simplicity is
usually
the key um you know i when you were
talking about different types of clients
uh
i'm paraphrasing obviously but you
mentioned like the engineer type that
that is very data driven
greg and i kind of smiled at each other
that's i don't know
98 of our audience would you say uh
i mean it's probably 80 of our
collective coaching clients
yeah yeah so we get a lot of that um
just because of the type of content that
we put out
um do you ever see clients like that who
um
[Music]
almost reject simplicity where like they
want to see
more things in motion like on the
coaching side
or if you don't give them if you don't
assign them
10 variables to track they're like no
i don't have homework this can't be
effective coaching like i need
i need something to do that's like super
time intensive and active to feel like
i'm getting my money's worth and getting
effective coaching
yeah i'm smiling and laughing as you're
saying this because i absolutely know
like that type of client and i and i
totally get it and if you don't give
them something with the quadratic
equation they're dis they're actively
disappointed
and uh you know these are people who are
likely to use terms like biohacking to
describe sleep and things like that
so i absolutely get that kind of client
and i think you know for me the way i
think about it is
you don't get to be team captain on your
first day right so
maybe you have the skill to do a super
complex program that's awesome
um but you have to show me you have to
demonstrate that you can do this
and we can ramp you up very quickly like
maybe by week two you're going to do
some baroquely elaborate program that's
fine
but there's an aspect of being able to
demonstrate that you have the capacity
for this and so
at precision nutrition we have this idea
of nutritional levels which
we're kind of like throwing around the
idea of getting away from the term
level because it kind of implies like
there's an upward progression and that
you get better
but it's not really like that it's more
like degrees of specialization
and and professional requirements right
so a level three client
is someone who has aesthetic goals
mostly
for their job like it is their job to
look a certain way and i think a great
example of that would be someone like
dwayne johnson whose whole job in life
is just to be
dwayne johnson right so his body uh
for the most part is his occupation and
so
that's a level three client or someone
who's a professional ufc fighter needs
to make weight that's a level
three client it's very short term
temporary you know for a
shoot or something like that a level two
client is a client that's
mastered a fairly high level of
skill so they can handle complexity and
they can do it consistently
so this would be someone like a
professional athlete who has mastered
the foundational skills
of you know those behaviors that you
need to be doing and then level one is
everyone including
athletes and celebrities because you
always start at level one
and the the defining feature
um i mean there's a few defining
features one is the degree of
specificity required and the degree of
like
how much skin in the game do you have to
go to level three
but the big defining feature is really
consistency
can you do the things over and over and
over and over again
and so you know any client can request
any ridiculous program
but you have to demonstrate that you can
do it it's like you don't let someone
walk into your gym on day one
and snatch 400 pounds right like it's
just
i don't care how much you want to you
just don't get allowed to do that
um so i mean that's it's a very
analogous process and i think
like using the experiential experimental
dimension of things
is a way to bring people on board so
rather than telling people
oh here's how you should do it you give
them a task and say
okay show me like let's gather data
about your life demonstrate to me that
you can execute this consistently and
competently
so now they're the ones gathering the
data and if they come back and say well
i did this three days out of seven
you're like okay what does the data show
right or what do the data show
so i mean data data driven people can go
one of two ways like they can go to the
super complex stuff or
they can be um
shown through the experience of their
own life which we call writing the
owner's manual
um what works for them and what doesn't
so i mean
it can swing either way and of course i
mean you're managing people's feelings
and expectations i mean
part of the job of a coach is to set
realistic expectations
so someone walks into your gym and
they're 20
body fat and they're like i want to be
five percent body fat in six weeks
your job as a coach is to say no
um and i think that's perfectly fine
it's the art of coaching is
isn't how you do it yeah i know you did
uh pick at a bit of a scab of mine you
mentioned dwayne johnson
i was oh dear well
so here's the back story i've been
working on finding a more suitable
co-host for my podcast
and i actually offered dwayne i i
offered him the job basically and
um it's been literally months and he
hasn't gotten back to me
um so we don't like to talk about him
too much on the show
yeah but too busy with his tequila
business i guess which
is understandable wait he has the
tequila business
oh yes yes he has the rocks tequila
interesting i don't think it's actually
him i think his people
aren't getting the message through to
him which is really frustrating
but in any case i would also assume and
i may be overstepping here i'd assume
his people are the ones making his
tequila i doubt he's making it by hand
you don't think he's making oh that's a
serious accusation
i'm just saying i i think it's worth at
least looking into
like probing a little more so i i
actually do have a follow-up based on
what you just said about
um you know making clients
kind of prove that they can handle one
level before advancing them further
have you noticed with anyone you've
worked with or
other coaches in your company have
worked with that sometimes you get
better adherence from kind of like
occasionally giving people a little bit
more
um maybe before they've proved that they
can handle less
so as background i don't do any
nutrition coaching whatsoever and so i'm
i'm reasoning
purely by analogy here from doing you
know training
coaching um but like for for a fair
amount of people i've worked with i used
to take that approach of
let's start everyone on something basic
prove that they can adhere to it and
then if they want to go crazy after that
we can make things a little crazier
um but one of the things i found was
that
for a lot of them if they came in
expecting
something super complicated and i gave
them something simple
they would very frequently kind of like
go off program and like add their own
little embellishments to it
because one of the things that like
helped them
comply and helped them think that the
program was going to be effective
was the fact that it was complicated and
so then
when i would add more complications even
though in theory
it should be harder to adhere to it was
more similar to what they wanted and
what they expected
so adherence actually improved um have
you ever noticed anything similar with
nutrition coaching or do you think
the two spheres are just so different
that that kind of
one doesn't apply to the other no i
think it's absolutely analogous and i
think different kinds of clients
like there is going to be the kind of
client that loves challenge and
and clients have different relationships
to challenge too like there are going to
be the clients that
any grain of challenge is going to
paralyze them like they're just going to
collapse and get completely demotivated
um other clients love to feel like
they're having a challenge and
i think of uh my friend jeff gervitz of
bank fitness in toronto
has this thing he does where he often
finishes especially new people
he finishes their workout with some sled
pushes and pulls and
the genius of this is that first of all
that feels like a really badass
task right like that's hardcore if
you're if you're not someone who
has grown up in a hardcore gym getting
presented with the sled that you're
pushing and pulling like that feels
super badass it's someone it's something
that most people can do
regardless of injuries or fitness level
can be scaled up or down like most
people unless they're really busted up
can push or pull a sled in some way even
for 10 seconds
but they and it's hard like it's very
effortful and you can pitch it
so that they feel like they've done some
work
maybe it's only literally for 30 seconds
or 60 seconds or whatever
but they they get the badass feeling at
the end of the workout which is what
they leave with which is
like that's their final impression of
how the workout was right and so
someone will say how does that work
workout and they're like oh my god jeff
killed me it was so amazing even if like
95
of that workout was rehab mobility
movements they will remember the sled
pushing
so i think there's absolutely something
to that
again i think it's very client specific
you have to work in their zone of
proximal development
and it really becomes a game of like
what's the thing that i can give them
that's not going to break them
but that will make them feel like
they're getting something special
eating slowly without distractions is
actually one of the killer apps for this
one
even just a day of doing it um
is a huge trip for a lot of people
because it is incredibly difficult like
their
their first minute of the first meal is
like oh my god this is
way harder than i expected so that's
just one example but there's lots of
examples that you could throw in there
right like epic amounts of colorful
fruit and vegetables
there's lots of things you can put in
there that doesn't break the person in
terms of like
distracting them from their mission or
getting them preoccupied with
relevant details or um getting paralyzed
by complexity or something like that
and an artful coach will kind of know
like oh yeah what's the thing that i can
add to the program what's the secret
sauce that i can add to the program
that makes the person feel like they're
getting a little something and i mean
what we're circling around is the idea
that
ultimately most people in coaching are
chasing a feeling
there's some way that they want to feel
and our job as coaches
is to figure out how to construct that
feeling for them
it's i mean like almost all of the goals
that we pursue in our lives
are an attempt to obtain a specific
feeling so as a coach
the better you get at it the more
intuitively you can jump to
understanding
this is what this person wants to feel
and this is how i can
stimulate that feeling for them as much
as possible yeah
like i said you know my background is
very much on the physiology side it's
uh very focused on numbers and formulas
and
would you say that that's a very common
uh mistake that a lot of people make
when they first get into nutrition
coaching is that they are
just focused on the nuts and bolts and
they don't really think about
the client experience or actually uh
setting up behaviors that are going to
be conducive
to to good adherence oh yeah i mean i
think that's a huge issue and i think
that is the curse of
knowledge in any field i mean you got
into this because you're interested in
it presumably you love it you studied it
at a fairly high level you
think about it you read books about it
you listen to podcasts about it
everyone listening to this listens to
podcasts about it um and we
forget how far away we are
from many of the people that we serve
and again a lot depends on your
population right
but like it's like teaching a beginner
to do even something like a basic
kettlebell swing
in your mind this is like baby stuff
hip hinge baby stuff but you know if you
go into the general population and
you see who can competently execute a
hip hinge even with the greatest
teaching
on their first day you realize gosh
there's a lot of
things to know here and so
hopefully the better you get as a coach
the more you realize
the gap that exists between you
and the person you're working with and
how to effectively bridge that gap
but i think it's really difficult
because we don't know what we don't know
anymore um
i have a an eight-year-old at home and i
was teaching her the other day
um how to tie her shoes we're still
working on shoe tying
and like i realized this is actually an
incredibly complicated skill like you
need
a lot of fine motor control and then
there's like some spatial stuff and then
changes right and left and you have to
like i was
trying to teach this and i was like oh
my god there's like 50 moving parts to
this so
i think we do forget how much we know
um how many connections we make
intuitively and
seamlessly like we can go from point a
to point
well i'll say z but it's z for us
canadians point a to point zed
you know in a single bound whereas our
client might need a b
c d so i i think it's definitely a
problem
for coaches especially newer coaches
because they're so excited to share
what they've learned and they're they're
marinating and all the terminology
you know so we're like hey you know do
something on your ipsilateral side and
the client is like
what what what is an ipsilateral side
so yeah i do i do think that is a
challenge and i mean ideally the more
you go along the more you're willing
i mean here's the other piece you want
to demonstrate how much you know
especially when you're newer like it's
super important to you
that people see you as an expert and
that they recognize your authority
and if you carry that forward into the
rest of your career
i think that's going to hamper you a
little bit because then you won't be
willing to simplify
you'll be like oh but if i simplify
everyone's going to think i'm dumb or
that my advice is too simple
but the art of it is really in making it
incredibly simple
and clear and accessible and inviting
people into that world so that maybe six
months from now
yeah maybe they'll have a sophisticated
understanding but
you know you need to bridge that gap
yeah that makes a lot of sense
um so my last question obviously was
about from the coach's perspective
you know what what are key mistakes that
some coaches make
early on uh when they get into coaching
but
i do want to focus a little bit on the
client's perspective
um you know a lot of people initiate
some kind of dietary intervention for
themselves and
uh i i'd say weight loss is probably
among the most common
what do you see from the client side um
in terms of like
the the really glaring mistakes that are
extremely common
you know like what what is kind of the
key predisposing factors to a client who
or an individual who embarks on this uh
this weight loss diet and ultimately
fails what are they overlooking in the
process do you think
well there's lots of pieces and to go
back to your first question about
numbers
one of the pieces a lot of coaches and
clients miss is what we would call a
biopsychosocial perspective what we call
a deep health perspective at precision
nutrition which is that
your life contains all of these
intersecting factors and
just making it about numbers or about
servings of protein or whatever
misses like the huge contribution that
the
all of the other aspects of your life
make so let's say for example
you have a long commute um if you're
leaving the house these days let's
imagine a time when we all left our
house
you know maybe you have a long commute
and and you're on the road early and
you've got kids and you've got a
stressful job
um you know and like all these factors
and you have to think about feeding your
kids and and making the you know
like juggling family meals and balancing
full-time employment all this kind of
stuff
what affects your nutritional decisions
will be so much outside of the realm of
grams of protein
so i think one of the big mistakes
people make is
just making it about the food or even
about the nutrients because we don't eat
nutrients we eat food we eat meals we
eat meals in context
we eat meals in an environment and a
whole life um
and so i think for me that's one big
piece that people just focus on
on the details but the the vastly
stronger factors affecting decisions are
the rest of your life
so it's really important to take kind of
a holistic perspective and say
what are some of the contributing
factors to my food decisions which may
or may not have anything to do with
nutrients i mean we can adjust nutrients
but the limiting factor in me eating
protein
may have nothing to do with being
assigned
x number of grams of protein so i think
that's a big one um
you know another one is not
having a growth mindset and not using
feedback loops and one of the great
things about data-driven people
is that they tend to grasp the idea of
feedback and feedback loops and they
tend to feel a little bit more neutral
about the data whereas other clients
you know they they do a week of
something and then they step on the
scale and the result isn't what they
expected
and then they're like ah screw it
there's no point to this and like they
spiral off into some you know shame
spiral or self-criticism or frustration
or whatever
rather than stepping back and saying
okay you know what are the data telling
me if i were to look objectively at
all of this what things could i tweak
and adjust so i think that most people
do not
use feedback and data effectively and
neutrally and as objectively as possible
and they go down the rabbit hole into
self-criticism which of course amplifies
the stress which amplifies the tendency
to go into stress coping behaviors which
you know we all know where that goes so
i think that's um
that's another really big piece um
and then you know i do think that most
people over complicate it and we're told
to overcomplicate it i mean the
nutrition industry
thrives on us over complicating things
but i think people do not understand
some of the fundamental principles that
make things work and i think
i mean as silly as it sounds i don't
think most people really grasped
that you have to create an energy
deficit if you want to lose weight like
it's
just the most fundamental fact no matter
how much you
you rearrange the cookies on the plate
or whatever how much you play with your
macronutrients or eat in the morning eat
at night eat standing on your head
like people forget the simple
energy in an energy out equation
there's lots of factors that can affect
that of course um
you know whatever your energy out is can
be affected by all kinds of things
you know some of these inputs and
outputs can be a little bit mysterious
but it doesn't change this fundamental
relationship
and so i think a lot of people have
trouble
just cutting through the crap and saying
okay no matter what else i do around
this i simply have to eat less energy
than i expend and for me there's like a
beautiful
simplicity about that everything else on
top of that
is just i don't want to say window
dressing but like
a little bit more extraneous
um for a weight loss client yeah now
throughout the the the interview here we
we've kind of come
close to a particular topic or mentioned
things related to it but we haven't
uh we haven't dove into that topic yet
so i want to transition really briefly
to
um you know you mentioned all these
different things that contribute to our
food decisions i want to talk a little
bit about people's
relationship with food um you know i
feel like in social me on social media
whenever i hear somebody
talking about nutrition it's really
really common to hear somebody say
i had a poor relationship with food and
now it's better what determines our
relationship with food
and more importantly what does fixing
someone's relationship with food look
like
actually trex yeah can that be a teaser
because i wanted to slide one more
coaching question in first sure yeah so
one thing that i have been curious about
just regarding pn for a long time
is uh one of the things one of the
things that i hear people
claim on social media and blogs etc
all the time is that like behavior and
habit change
isn't sexy that that's the effective
thing
for you know maintaining health and
losing weight etc etc
but like you can't sell people on that
it's not exciting it's not sexy
and i mean one of one of my responses to
that is like
well [ __ ] look at pn because that
kind of seems to be their whole jam
and they seem to be you know quite
successful both with helping people
lose weight and keep it off and in terms
of being able to sell it and be a very
successful business
so just in general how how would you
respond
to that notion that you know habits and
behavior change aren't
sexy and then what have you guys done at
pn
to make it more you know exciting sexy
uh sellable to the customer and also
sellable to clients to get them to
adhere and buy in
i've never really thought of behavior
changes sexy before so now you've given
me more things to think about
um you know i i think well you you can
you can substitute that with exciting
yeah no i know i i'm gonna roll with
sexy i'm i'm gonna stay with that um
you know i think i think this is one of
the foundational challenges
for anyone in a domain
that does require repeated and
potentially unexciting behaviors whether
that is learning an instrument
learning a new language studying for
university
putting in the reps in the gym i mean
the fundamental fact is that we live
if you're in north america we live in a
culture
where our relationship to long-term
sustained effort is a little bit broken
and we love the cinderella story so to
speak we love overnight successes even
though
you know that doesn't really exist but
we're in love with like the collective
fiction of fast results
um so i think the first step is kind of
realizing that that is a cultural
narrative
that we have and so like you're never
going to completely override it because
you know it's a fundamental human desire
to
have quick transcendence i was just
listening to uh something on
the radio the other day about about john
milton's paradise lost right like
someone was thinking about transcendence
200 years ago and i'm sure humans were
thinking about it
3 000 years ago like basically the
question is how can i get the hell out
of where i
am right now that's a fundamental human
desire
so i think kind of recognizing and
allowing that to be the case
uh is is not wrong but
i think there's something that we also
know in the back of our minds
all of us that cinderella is just a
story
and i think all of us have
gone the route of trying something for
quick transcendence and finding it
ultimately unfulfilling
so there's two human needs here right
one of them is quick fix quick
transcendence
and another one is like the human
self-awareness that like all of the
things that we've tried haven't worked
like it's the human frustration right so
i think we like to speak a lot to
the hey listen you've tried a bunch
of crap you know it doesn't work like
between the two of us
you know what the real deal is and so we
speak to that person that's come out the
other end of the quick fix
quick fix process and is feeling a
little bit disillusioned
frustrated lost confused they feel like
throwing in the towel
we speak to that human feeling
and we're like we're like you know in
the alley like pushing behavior change
like hey man you want to try some
behavior change like that
first habit is free um and and we give
and
and we also invite curiosity so rather
than saying
hey everyone should be doing habit
change we're like
hey would you like to try something so
i mean another human thing is curiosity
people are curious and so can we harness
the curiosity
in the service of getting them going in
the right direction and so this kind of
comes back to the sled pushing idea of
harnessing human curiosity in the
service of doing the right thing
can we find a game to play with people
an
experiment to invite them to try
something that sparks their curiosity
enough that they're willing to take the
gateway drug
and discover how it works for them so um
you know it's like behavior change is
probably never going to be
super sexy but i think
most people come to the dawning
realization
that whatever they're doing isn't
working
and that's the person that we speak to
like are you sick of all of the crap are
you sick of the diets
look you tried this and this and this
you know it doesn't work
why don't you come hang out with us uh
you know we like to say that we're like
an island of sanity in an ocean of crazy
i think on some level most people are
longing
for that like that just they want to
step out of the
frazzle you know and the the craziness
to just
find some sanity and so we don't really
speak to the people for whom this is
their first rodeo
we speak to what i call refugees from
the diet scene people who are just
exhausted
by the crap so part of it i think is
speaking to people who are ready to hear
the message
you know that makes all the sense in the
world to me because i mean
out in in the diet world there's so much
that you have to wade through
i mean anybody that's tried to lose
weight a few discrete times
has probably been promised if you just
cut carbs
and they try that and they're like ah
that didn't really do it well if you
just cut
fat and they try that you know and if
you just cut breakfast or if you just
cut dinner at a certain point
i would imagine you you guys
collectively are just standing there
like
it's time you know like yeah yeah
totally
totally it's time and you know i think
it's it's really interesting to have
aged along with the fitness industry
because the fitness and nutrition
industry
are typically very young industries but
i'm seeing a lot of people that i
followed 20 years ago or even 30 years
ago
are now saying hey i'm i'm old and all
the kind of
things i was saying 20 years ago about
being hardcore
yeah you know what um i don't believe
them anymore and so i think
that i think the fitness and nutrition
industry has also matured
in a way i mean there's always going to
be crap out there but i think
like some of the the voices that have
persisted in the industry
are maturing along with their bodies and
saying different things about
how stuff works and i don't think it's
the predominant
uh tone of things but i do think that
there's kind of a maturity to the
industry that
you know maybe wasn't around um a few
decades ago
yeah that that makes a ton of sense uh
your answer to the prior question was
far more existential than i was banking
on
but was absolutely excellent well i mean
here's the thing right like we
we we can't sell i mean our pn coaching
program i designed it as a life change
program
right like it re it revises you from the
inside out
but we cannot sell it like that and so i
mean
a part of the art of marketing and
coaching is telling people
to some degree what they think they want
to hear but giving them what they
actually need
and that is the game that we're all
playing and and putting it in language
that is intelligible
so i mean we don't sell pn coaching as
hey we're going to overhaul your life
you may dramatically rethink your
relationships and who you are in the
world you may quit your job like
i mean all of these things have happened
i've joked that we break up marriages
like because
as people come to a greater awareness of
themselves and and the issues that shape
their lives
they start to see a lot of things way
more clearly right so but we can't sell
it like that so i mean we do talk about
getting in shape and changing your body
all that kind of stuff
so like what you tell people on the
surface as well
maybe you have a little bit more leeway
with that than what you actually
offer them and that is the art is is
giving people
again what they truly need while making
them think
it's what they want now i i have an idea
you're free to take it or leave it
if fundamentally what you're doing is
overhauling people's lives
in the next book y'all put out uh you
could include
a deity figure and then reincorporate as
a religion
and possibly save on some tax money um
you know i like where this is going do
with that what you will
yeah what's the worst idea let's circle
back to that question trex had like 15
minutes ago
uh just a quick self-serving one one of
the like
really notable characteristics of my
personality is that i'm mostly dead
inside
do you think you have a do you have a
nutrition program for that
so you have the thousand yard stare well
i mean we can just get you going through
the motions right we can we can
you know construct you like a life
exoskeleton so you can just repeat a
series of of pattern
movements and and actions that make you
feel like you're living a full life
that'd be i yearn for that
shut the [ __ ] up okay
um yeah i did want to get back to the
question that i teased
earlier um before greg grabbed the
microphone so
one of the themes that i've seen more
and more and more
in the nutrition discourse on social
media is
speaking about an individual's
relationship with
food and you kind of mentioned way
toward the beginning of the interview
that there are a lot of things that kind
of shape that
and i guess what i would hope for this
podcast or for this part of the podcast
is that
someone who's curious like do i have a
good relationship with food
that they can get some clarity about
like what does that mean and and what
can an individual hope to
to truly do about that if that makes
sense
yeah and i mean there's a lot embedded
in your question so i'll try to pull it
apart i mean we have actually been
thinking about this quite a lot me and
my colleagues
uh about like is there a way to
assess someone's relationship with food
i mean there are clinical instruments
but like
not pn style right like pn style is a
different way of thinking about things
and so like is there a way to
drill down people's relationship with
food into a series of indicators or a
series of questions that you could
ask i mean coaching to me in a way is
about asking the right questions right
and and not
more than you need but just exactly the
right amount and so there i think
certain questions that you can ask
people that will start to get at
you know their health of their
relationship with food and
i mean it's a lot analogous to the
health of a relationship with a person
right um does my relationship with this
person
take up an appropriate amount of mental
and emotional real estate
um you know and obviously different
people will inhabit our lives in
different ways right the the amount of
mental real estate your kid takes up
should be different than the amount of
mental real estate that like your
neighbor takes up unless your neighbor's
also your kid but that's you know you
see what i'm saying
um so it's the same with food right you
want to be
thinking about food or you know planning
food or problem solving around food
just the right amount so not so little
that you're just mindlessly
putting food in the food hole but not so
you know all consuming that it's all you
think about and all you do and i'm
always a little bit like hesitant with
people who are like oh
i'm a real foodie and i have a blog
about food and i think about food all
the time and i'm like
you know i don't want to discourage you
from your hobby but you may want to
examine that
and how it how it operates for you in
your life so i mean question number one
is
what's an appropriate amount of
psychological
and life real estate that you're
devoting to this relationship
and is it crowding out other
potentially more fulfilling activities
pursuits
and so forth so for example is your
relationship with food
crowding out your relationship with
other actual human beings
or with activities that might bring
meaning to your life or teach you new
skills or something like that
um are you expanding and i don't mean
physically but like i
go back to the existential are you
becoming a bigger better person
as a result of this relationship or are
you becoming a smaller
more narrow person as a result of this
relationship
that's a good question to ask
you know we're looking for the balance
of
just the correct amount and as someone
is learning a new relationship with food
they may be thinking about it more they
may be talking about it more they may be
digesting so to speak more stuff around
it
but ideally our hope is that it settles
into a place of appropriateness
where it's just the right amount another
thing about
you know a fulfilling relationship with
a person is that there's a give and take
there's mutuality right you don't
um love the other person
more than they love you in the sense of
like you know are like are you over
loving and are they draining you
right you don't want that kind of
asymmetrical relationship ideally you
want a relationship of mutuality so
if you think about a relationship with
food
are you gaining value from your choices
are your choices
nourishing you are they adding value to
your body are they improving
your performance or your recovery or
your function or whatever
um but you know is is there a level of
symmetry
in that relationship you're getting
something out of it you know it's giving
something to you
that's another way to know it but i
think you know for me
like honestly one question that will
tell you pretty much everything is what
what's the level of mental real estate
and what are the emotions
around this you know is this prompting
calm uh sanity a sense of
peace clarity uh
compassion like is it provoking these
or is it provoking anxiety depression
self-criticism
panic worry um complete cluelessness
like
what is the emotional experience that
you're having
um are you having some of those more
calm balanced emotions and i mean to go
back to the feeling that people want to
have
a lot of time my clients will say things
like i want to feel more confident
i want to trust myself i want to feel
more
calm i want to feel more balanced so i
think for me those are indicators that
you're moving in
in the right direction and then i mean
there are there are granular indicators
every day that you can look at right
like
am i making a choice that truly adds
value
to my body and to my life am i eating my
colorful fruits and vegetables am i
eating my protein
am i getting overly rigid am i you know
what degree of adaptability do i have
something else you don't want in
relationships is to get overly rigid
oh this person you know must always do
this and it should always be like that
well i mean that's not the nature of
human relationships right and
and with food it's the same thing do you
get stressed out
if you cannot control your food
or if you cannot abide by rigid
parameters how
strict how rigid is this or how flexible
how adaptable can you can you adapt on
the fly are you resilient are you
creative are you resourceful
that tells you a lot about your
relationship with food as well
as soon as i heard the term control with
a client i'm like let's think about that
so i mean that's that's sort of a
lengthy answer but uh you know hopefully
it gives people a few
clues that they can at least ask
themselves about
yeah i think that's a really terrific
perspective on it and
i will say you know i come from the
perspective
uh i'm from the bodybuilding world you
know bodybuilding physique
figure all that stuff and so my exposure
to content about relationships with food
from my little um area of fitness
there seems to be an enormous overlap
where where
uh you know self-identified poor
relationships with food
tend to correlate very highly with body
image issues
uh is that something that is seen more
broadly or i mean
when we were first when we first started
talking you mentioned things like past
trauma is it just that i'm seeing it
through a very very narrow scope
well you know it's interesting you ask
because there are people who
who have a physique and bodybuilding
background that have always seemed to
just
be healthy and sane about it and so that
you know part of it is probably a set of
personality traits
uh that allow a person to be healthy and
sane and balanced and kind of pragmatic
about it and you know not get too
overwrought about it but devote some
level of attention to it
like there's probably a set of
personality traits that um
allow a person to be in the physique
world but emerge
unscathed if i can say that um
but a significantly larger proportion of
people
uh do come out of the physique and
bodybuilding world
talking about a messed up relationship
with food so
um i also like to think about like not
just where people are right now
but where are they going to be in six
months 12 months five years from now 10
years from now
so if we look at the long-term
trajectory of things a lot of people who
are currently messed up about food
um you know a kind of over
focus on food which is intrinsic to the
physique world
was one of the precipitating factors but
it's certainly not the only
precipitating factor i mean we know that
nutrient restriction itself can cause
problems with food right there's the
famous starvation studies i noticed this
when i was working with a lot of
fighters people who were cutting weight
like guys like young guys who'd never
had body issues before
were acquiring body issues and weird
food hoarding issues and weird food
behaviors like
driving around in their car at 3am
looking for giant bags of cashews like
stuff like that
um you know they acquired these things
as a result of
the nutrient deprivation and the energy
deprivation of
weight cutting combined with hard
training so like that for me was super
interesting how you can almost
give someone disordered eating if you
restrict them enough
and then people come to it from other
pathways right maybe you were
you know quote unquote the fat kid and
you know your parents were on you but
going on a diet from age
seven and your you know peers picked on
you like maybe that was your pathway
into this
or again yeah maybe you had some kind of
trauma maybe you grew up poor
there wasn't a lot of food in the house
you know and you got kind of stuck on it
that way so there's
there's lots and lots of pathways into a
difficult relationship with food
but certainly one of the ones that will
almost
i don't say almost certainly but in the
vast majority of cases
give you a problem if you didn't have
one is
prolonged chronic
nutrient and energy deprivation that's
almost like your express train
down the road to having issues
definitely yeah well um very very
interesting interview that we've had up
at this point
um a lot of stuff that uh i i think is
is going to be super useful to our
audience because we rarely get to dive
into these topics because uh
greg and i don't know anything about
them so uh
really really appreciate your time and
that you've been willing to share your
expertise with us
um one thing i did want to ask you
before we sign off here
um it says on the precision nutrition
website
that you're pretty adamant that people
should learn some basic cooking skills
to uh to support their nutrition
endeavors
is it safe to assume that you're pretty
into cooking yourself as a hobby
you know i am but the funny thing is i'm
not super good at it and here's why
because for me it's more i'm i'm one of
those people that will do a job
to 80 completion i'm a little bit add
kind of a lot add
um and so my my attention to the
precision required to be a good cook
like to put
you know to be careful about measuring
and that kind of stuff and following
instructions and not substituting
ridiculously
um i'm i'm not as good at
that and so like i have a lot of
enthusiasm for cooking i enjoy it i find
it relaxing i do it a lot
but i don't have the requisite um
patience or i'm really bad with rules
and instructions i've always been my
my whole life so i'm probably a less
good cook than someone who would
patiently and diligently and carefully
follow a recipe with very little cooking
expertise
but yeah that being said i do i do enjoy
it and i do
love it and i do think it's fun what are
some of your favorite things to cook
you know i love anything that seems
complicated but isn't really uh like a
roast chicken
you know like when you when you buffed
out a roast chicken everyone's like oh
my god that's amazing you're like
literally
you open the oven door shove the thing
in and come back in an hour right
or even something like butterflying a
chicken um you know
like if you're willing to just get in
there and hack stuff up it's really not
that complicated so
i mean baking is a whole other world
like baking i don't do because that's
far too meticulous um but anything like
roasty anything like applying fire like
that is my jam i um i now live in an
apartment where i can't do this but for
a long time i was getting really into
smoking
i was smoking everything like well you
know like can i smoke this can i smoke
that i had a a green egg which was
wonderful um so i was smoking super into
smoking like everything that i could
think about alcoholic drinks how does
this work
so yeah that was my jam for a while
that's awesome
yeah the stronger by science podcast
basically the last
20 of every episode is greg talking
about cooking so i
everything you're talking about is very
much right up his alley
one recommendation i would have next
time you're you're doing some
roasting with any kind of bird where is
this going
if i were you i would spatchcock the
bird
[ __ ] up eric it's just a technique i
taught greg about where if you're gonna
roast the birds right you want to
spatchcock
it for sure it just brings out so much
flavor
cooks right through very evenly you know
and there are those little like
um i don't use the term hacks but
there's like there are some things in
the world that like are really super
high leverage activities and like using
butter is another one right like
everyone's like oh what does restaurant
food taste so good it's because they use
cream and butter like butter makes
everything better and i think it's
something that fitness people are like
oh my god better like we we tell people
um at pm like butter is okay to eat and
everyone's like
oh my god so rebellious i mean it's not
like go stick a
thing of butter in your coffee and i
mean we're not going down that road but
there is something magical about butter
uh
that really is like the killer app for
for making
food uh amazing yeah greg showed me a
video one time of making scrambled eggs
and it was like what were the
proportions on that
is so it was a gordon ramsay scrambled
egg recipe
and it was one tablespoon of butter
per egg plus an additional tablespoon of
butter to
finish the emulsion so i i think i think
it was three eggs
no it was four eggs and five tablespoons
of butter
plus a little uh creme fraiche yeah it
was
a little more indulgent than my macros
could handle but someday
i'll work my way up it was it was legit
like
70 80 grams of fat for breakfast
you need to set aside a whole day for
that like that's a commitment i think
oh yeah that was like bulletproof eggs
bulletproof eggs definitely
well krista like i said uh we we really
appreciate
uh the fact that you'd spend the time
with us and share some of your expertise
with us
uh if people want to stay in touch with
you or kind of uh
keep up to up to date with what you're
working on where can people find you
well the best place to start is probably
precisionnutrition.com
you know i'm pretty active on the blog
there so you can go and you can
i mean read tons of free stuff including
things that i've written
you know you can find me on on the
facebooks you can find me on instagram
often i'll post links to things like
podcasts i've done
um on instagram i'm at stumptuous um so
those are really the best places to find
me
uh and krista scott dixon is not such a
common name
if you google me i should not be that
difficult to locate
awesome well thank you so much for
joining us take care
have a great day thanks you too
thanks for listening to the stronger by
science podcast now
greg and i are not experts in medicine
or health or
really anything else for that matter so
before you make any changes to your diet
and exercise habits make sure you check
with a doctor
or another health care professional if
you enjoyed this podcast and you'd like
to support it
visit strongerbyscience.com to check out
the products and services that we offer
thanks for listening and we'll see you
next time
[Music]
[Music]
you